also es ist jetzt wirklich dramatisch
was da passiert es den letzten stunden
gestern gab es eine beschlussvorlage des
bundeskanzleramtes um 21 55 wurde die
verschickt also fünf minuten vor 22 uhr
10 uhr am abend und darin gab es einen
großen also eine ganze seite zum thema
schule und zur verschärfung der regeln
für schüler unter einer bar eine massen
pflicht vorgeschlagen worden für
grundschüler im unterricht aber auch auf
dem pausenhof also nicht nur für
grundstock für alle schüler beginnt ab
der grundschule auch für lehrer es war
auch so was wie ein schnupfen quarantäne
gefordert worden
das heißt wer schnupfen hat als schüler
soll zu hause bleiben sieben tage lang
und es war gefordert waren die klassen
zu halbieren
also bei einer klasse von 30 plötzlich
nur noch 15 schüler zu unterrichten die
anderen dann in der woche drauf oder am
nachmittag wie auch immer also es war
auf jeden fall vieles vieles zum thema
schule trennen deutlich härtere
maßnahmen als wir sie heute
bisher haben und danach gab es richtig
krach und zwar heute morgen
cdu-präsidium das um 8 uhr getagt hat
und danach auch im bundesvorstand ab 39
und das ende vom lied ist dass die
bundeskanzlerin sagen musste okay wir
streichen diesen ganzen schulkomplex aus
der beschlussvorlage es gibt es eine
neue beschlussvorlage an dieser neuen
beschlussvorlage ist das thema schule
gar nicht mehr erwähnt oder kommt nur
noch am rande vor das heißt dass die
bundesländer jetzt eine woche zeit haben
ihre vorschläge zum thema schule zu
formulieren also dass man sich am
nächsten montag wieder trifft und dann
zum thema schule noch mal neu berät ja
aber ein problem verschieben das macht
es für den moment ja eigentlich nicht
besser wenn es jetzt gar nicht erwähnt
wird das heißt bis nächste woche geht es
ganz normal weiter und selbst dann muss
man davon ausgehen sie können ja nicht
verein auf den anderen tag solche dinge
umsetzen also schule bleibt die
kommenden wochen eigentlich so wie sie
jetzt gerade sind also zumindest ist es
aufatmend für eltern jetzt erstmal für
die nächsten fünf tage glaube ich
hörbaren dass sie wissen es geht erstmal
immer noch mal regeln unterschiedlichen
die bundesländer aber erstmal so weiter
wie bisher und dann wird die große frage
sein auf was werden sich die
ministerpräsidenten der
ministerpräsidenten am nächsten montag
denn verständigt mit der bundeskanzlerin
so und wenn man das nicht was in der
beschlussvorlage heute oder bis 10 uhr
dann gab es die neue beschlusslage drin
stand was aber zu massiver kritik
geführt hat dann kann man zumindest
einen weg sehen wo es hingehen könnte
also das thema
kleinere klassen ist sicherlich weiter
auf der agenda gibt einige
ministerpräsidenten die sagen nein
wollen sie auf keinen fall haben aber
andere sagen es muss sein um das
infektionsgeschehen zu reduzieren dann
ist die frage der masken kriegt
natürlich extrem wichtig gibt aber auch
selbst natürlich mütter und väter im
cdu-präsidium die heute noch mal gesagt
haben nein wir haben selbst schulkinder
wir wissen können mit masken gar nicht
lernen also da gibt es dann auch um
praktische dinge und das ist manchmal
ganz gut wenn auch eltern mit
entscheiden und selbst sagen massen
pflicht ist quatsch das behindert unsere
schülerinnen unsere kinder beim lernen
also es wird spannend sein zu sehen wie
der weg den nächsten fünf sechs tage
lang ist aber es wird auf jeden fall
viel viel konfliktpotenzial und viel
streit noch geben um das thema schule
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren